[Music]  saying goodbyes  saying hello  you think your wife can hear you  no  iBall  Maybe I'm Wrong  to die  maybe not goodbye to you my trusted  friend  [Music]  a new day is Dawning  new ideas the wounds  New Management we  've never seen  [Music]  who is this  challenging to single combat with a  loose it's a way out  I don't sit at the table your family  does please pray for me  [Music]  man has to look his best when it's time  to get married  or buried  I'm going to need a gun  by my friend  [Music]  if you win  the table will honor its word  we will have your freedom  under the old laws only one can survive  to meet at sunrise  will result in execution  Last Words Winston just have fun are  they  [Music]  I want you to find your peace but the  good death  only comes after a good life  you and I left a good life behind a long  time ago my friend  [Music]